now it's time for you to add the
functionality to save entities to your
app let's see how you can achieve that
okay so here I'm looking at the save
profile method in the conference API
class if you recall we already have the
code to create a new profile we just
call new on the profile and pass in the
arguments that we need creating the new
profile entity is as simple as calling
new on the profile class if we weren't
using objectify the code would be more
complicated you already have the code to
create a new profile object but you
don't need to make any changes now that
the profile has been identified as an
entity however creating an entity
doesn't automatically save it in the
datastore you have to explicitly save it
if you want it saved okay I'm going to
go ahead and add the code to save the
profile entity in the datastore you're
going to be writing this code yourself
in your own app in just a minute
though I'll run the app again on
localhost and go to the api's explorer
so here I am in the API Explorer and I'm
going to go into the save profile method
again and execute it and have a lemon
cake as my display name set my t-shirt
size to M and execute it oops I forgot
to authorize let's try that again
first I'll authorize authorize now I can
execute the function again I don't need
to enter the values just press execute
and there it goes just creating my
profile and you see here the request set
the display name to lemon cake t-shirt
size to medium to M the response
returned a profile with these fields so
the response shows that the profile was
created but this time hopefully it was
more than created it was actually saved
in the datastore and we can use the
datastore admin to check that so now I'm
going to go to the admin console on
localhost to get to the admin console
you go to the port where your app is
running which is for me that's localhost
colon 8080 and then it's slash
underscore aah slash admin
and this takes us to the data store
viewer the data straw admin for
localhost opens you can see here that it
doesn't know what my app ID is this is
your app ID and that's okay because
localhost doesn't care what the app ID
is of course when I actually want to
deploy to app spot I will need to
provide a real app ID the admin console
opens by default showing the datastore
viewer but if you're somewhere else and
you want to get back to the datastore
viewer or for some reason it doesn't
open there by default you just click
this datastore viewer and there you are
in the datastore viewer this entity kind
menu shows the different kinds of
entities that are stored in your
datastore right now the only one we've
got is profile you can click list
entities to see all the entities of that
kind that have already been saved
they'll probably the only one entity now
which is the profile that we just saved
so the datastore viewer shows you the
entities and it shows you the properties
we've got display name main email
t-shirt size okay so that was just a
quick review of how to save the entity
in the datastore and how to go to the
admin console on localhost to look at
your entities you're going to be doing
that now